[Music]
hey guys it's Johanna here some of you
have requested a video of my healthy
bread recipe a probably 20 faith is also
known as zucchini bread day and so I am
going to share with you my healthy and
delicious zucchini bread
the typical zucchini bread calls for a
lot of and sugar and oil from my recipe
we will be replacing it with banana and
honey and instead of using white or
whole wheat flour I'll be using a
combination of rice and oats flour of
course you may still use whole wheat
flour however it is worth noting that
rye contains higher fiber in comparison
to whole wheat and rye keeps you
satisfied for much longer because the
fiber in rye bread has a high water
binding capacity which expands during
digestion and produces a great feeling
of fullness
rye is also low English Simek index and
rye bread is recommended for a healthy
weight maintenance and also weight loss
to make my healthy and delicious
zucchini bread the ingredients you'll
need are one and a half cups of rye
flour 1/2 cup of oat flour 1 tablespoon
of baking powder 1 and a half cups of
the zucchini shredded which also equals
to one and a half medium zucchinis 2
tablespoons of honey
2x quarter cup of milk 1 large banana
mashed one teaspoon of vanilla extract
and half a teaspoon of mixed herbs or
cinnamon or nutmeg the first step is to
preheat the oven to 180 degrees Celsius
or 350 degrees Fahrenheit start by
shredding Vasuki nice with a grater or
food processor just like what I'm doing
in One Bowl combine all the dry
ingredients rye flour oat flour baking
powder and mix herbs in another bowl
mash the banana whisk in the eggs then
add the milk honey and vanilla extract
mix them well then combine the wet
ingredients with the dry ingredients
finally add in the shredded zucchini and
continue mixing until you have a thick
and moist batter grease one loaf pan
with cooking spray pour the batter into
the loaf pan and make sure it is level
in the pan then bake it in the oven for
50 to 60 minutes or until a toothpick
inserted in the center comes out clean
allowed this zucchini bread to cool down
for 15 minutes before removing from pan
then cool it down again for another 15
minutes before slicing your zucchini
bread should be slightly moist each loaf
mix about 14 slices and each slice has
86 calories it is delicious on its own
or you can spread some jam or peanut
butter on top it up with poached egg I
like to have two slices for breakfast
one with gel and another with poached
egg this bread is so healthy packed full
of fiber from the oats rye and zucchini
it has no added sugar and no added oil
hence being low in calories as well it
is a great way to pack more vegetables
from the zucchini fruit from the banana
complex carbs from the Rye and oats and
protein from the eggs I would definitely
suggest this for breakfast to boost your
metabolism with your energy and to curb
hunger try it out make it on zucchini
bread day and share your picture with me
on Facebook or Instagram for new Fitness
food and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my youtube
channel and website do you follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter to stay
connected with me thanks guys
[Music]